a day like this it's so important to our
community to help heal what does it mean
to you
well this is
one of those times when you have a rush
of memory the things that affected you
on the day that
we're all here to
remember it was
what struck me most about
as i thought about it is that i just
wanted to find a way to help
and as i've talked to people hundreds
maybe thousands of people over the
course of the years that have passed
that's what was going on in everyone's
mind and and so when we think about
where we are today
we're
we're probably
far less united today than we've been
right
and that taught us that there is a way
for us to find what we have in common
and then work to try and do something
together to help one another and i i
think if there were anything that it
reminds me of it reminds me that we
found ourselves as a community and now
the struggle is to keep ourselves
together wow well that was one thing
that struck me was how well the
community came together in the moments
the weeks the the days and now the years
so before i let you go
as far as the planning goes this is
quite an event and it's so important to
our community to everyone
it really is i there's so much that
comes from remembering
remembering the people the individuals
the losses reminding ourselves that
there's still people that are suffering
intensely some physically because they
were injured others because of the
losses they've had others because of the
trauma that this brought into a
community's life it's important for us
to hail back to the things that are
really important and what was really
important then was each one of us and
the contribution we might make to
provide something of relief to another
being that community again commissioner
gibson thank you so much for your time
this morning
folks at home we have so much more
coming up as as we prepare to mark this
very special very poignant very somber
day
in the meantime of course you can watch
all of that the sunrise ceremony is
going to be streaming on our website